ccsd superintendent dr jesus jarrah says  he is committed to keeping the community  involved in the district we learned you  know when we closed down our schools  connecting kids was kind of the road map  right i mean public private partnership  so there's there's there's room and  there's space for everyone to be  involved dr jara speaking at a virtual  town hall tonight to share how ccsd is  spending 770 million dollars in federal  funding it will go towards things like  teacher recruitment support for parents  and mental health services dr jarrow  will speak to a u.s house subcommittee  that is tomorrow about the impact of the  covid pandemic